how's it going everybody it's Warren and
today we got a supposed Marvel phase
four slate leak now I say supposed it
because it's questionable whether or not
this is just fanfiction or if it could
be legitimate because the person that
posted it did say that it will be
revealed at San Diego comic-con which is
coming up so this person does claim that
the slate they posted is legitimate and
will be revealed very soon and since
everybody is talking about it right now
I'll go ahead and read the lineup and
then break it down quick reminder about
my giveaway at the 450,000 subscriber
mark I will be picking three winners and
each winner will get to choose one item
from the Marvel Legends series
collection so be sure to subscribe and
like the video so you can enter the
giveaway so this Marvel phase 4 leak was
posted on Reddit and 4chan and like I
said even though this person claims that
it's going to be revealed at San Diego
comic-con it does sound like fanfiction
so here's what this person says the
lineup is in 2020 on May 1st we have
Black Widow and then on November 6th we
have the Eternals in 2021 on February
12th we have shang-chi on May 7th we
have guardians of the galaxy vol 3 on
November 5th we have Doctor Strange
sorcerer supreme in 2022 on February
18th we have Black Panther allied on May
7th we have Captain Marvel higher
further faster on July 22nd we have
ant-man the wasp and the stinger
then in 2023 on April 28th we have
Avengers Secret Wars and on August 4th
we have powerpack
the leaker also goes on to state that
there are films being highly considered
right now and those films are a third
spider-man film an Incredible Hulk
sequel named where the Submariner movie
and Nova movie a Howard the Duck movie
and a Moon Knight movie so that's the
Marvel phase 4 lineup according to this
leak and also movies that Marvel is
considering doing in Marvel's phase 4 so
even though a lot of people are talking
about this right now and this person
claims that this slate is going to be
revealed at San Diego comic-con I don't
think it's real it's stating movies that
we've already known from either of
previous leaks or something that Marvel
has kind of announced already and really
all it did was give the movies we've
already known to be coming out a
subtitle but the real giveaway that this
is not legitimate is the films that they
say are being highly
sidered they say a third spider-man film
is being highly considered but we know
that this is going to happen Marvel and
Sony signed a deal for three solo
spider-man films so we have one left no
matter what so it doesn't need to be
highly considered it's already happening
but then it says we're getting a solo
Hulk film Universal owns the rights to
solo Hulk films Marvel can't technically
use the Hulk in a solo film and that's
why we've seen him in other movies such
as the Avengers films and Thor Ragnarok
and then it states that Howard the Duck
is getting his own solo film however
Howard the Duck is already getting his
own animated series on Hulu and this has
been confirmed but really the main
giveaway to me is that it states there's
going to be an Avengers secret war movie
and it states that we're going to be
getting it in 2023 I don't think we're
going to get another Avengers film that
soon sadly and that's why I think this
leak is probably mostly fan fiction even
though this person says that this exact
slate is going to be revealed at San
Diego comic-con I do not think it's real
now I could be wrong and it could be
real but a lot of people are getting
very excited about this and I don't
think it's real fortunately we don't
have too much longer to wait for San
Diego comic-con because it starts July
18 so hopefully we will have some
official confirmation for Marvel's face
for slate then but let me know what you
think about this latest leak do you
think that it could be real or do you
think that it's fake let me know your
thoughts in the comments down below and
again a reminder about my giveaway if
you'd like to enter for your chance to
win a Marvel legend series collection
item all you have to do is be subscribed
to my channel like the video and comment
down below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero or villain also be
doing some giveaways on Instagram and
Twitter starting pretty soon if you want
to follow me on there as well as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
you